tell them to come in it's okay or I I
will bring
the
again okay so welcome to the third talk
on on constraint satisfaction today
given by Fon
kitis thank you Dan and let me thank the
organizers for for giving me the
opportunity to talk to you about this
joint work with albertas at PC
Barcelona the topic of this talk has to
do with the interplay between local
consistency and Global consistency and
at an intuitive level I'd like to
illustrate this with these two images
the image on the left is a piece of art
many of you if not all recognize it as
the drawing ascending and descending of
mcsr uh if you look at any particular
spot on this
drawing things look perfectly fine they
are perfectly consistent yet the whole
image depicts an impossible design so
this is a state of affairs that would be
described as being locally consistent
but globally
inconsistent the image on the right at
the first side looks almost as
paradoxical as the image on the left yet
this is something which is physically
realized perhaps the Greeks in the
audience would recognize that this is
from sorini the island of sorini in
Greece so we have this interplay between
local consistency versus global
consistency and the fact of the matter
is that when you go to science there are
several different
settings H where the objects of study
are locally consistent in a way that has
to be defined each time but they happen
to be globally
inconsistent such settings include a
Quantum information Theory
where the term is contextuality
indicating a state of affairs where
things are locally consistent but
globally inconsistent probability Theory
constraint satisfaction and database
Theory this has given rise to a research
program whose goal is to understand the
structural aspects of global consistency
we use a nice phrase that I have taken
from Samson abramsky can we
unveil the intelligence structure of
global consistency but a nice term and
in particular closer to what we want to
do here when is local consistency
equivalent to Global
consistency as it is usually the case we
stand on the shoulders of
giants an early giant here is Nikolai
vev who in
1962 characterized when a family of
probability distributions defined on
overlapping sets of variables has a
joint distribution meaning a
distribution whose projections on the
corresponding set of variables give you
each of the given probability
distributions on the database
side kriel bir Ron fagin David Meer and
M yanakakis in 1983 unaware of the work
of
ORF characterized when a family of
database relations with overlapping sets
of attributes has a universal
relation and the goal of the work that
I've done with Albert is to provide a
common
generalization of the results of bobf
and
Bal and this is a unifying framework for
studying local versus global consistency
that uses K relations where K is a
positive
sem now before getting to the K
relations and stating this result that
we have uh I want to provide some
background from database Theory and in
particular make sure that every on is on
the same Bo concerning the
banag
theor basic concepts relations they have
a set of
attributes we will write R parenthesis X
to indicate the relation whose sets of
attributes the names of its columns is
the set X we will write R square bracket
Z where this a subset of x to indicate
that this is the projection on r on the
attributes of the set Z and here is an
example of taking the projection of the
relation R BC on the attributes A and
B now come the Notions from the be M
anakis paper two relations are
consistent if there is a relation whose
attributes is the union of the sets of
attributes of the given relations so
that when you project this relation t on
X you get when you project it on y you
get
S and then if you have a family of
relations each with a corresponding sets
of attributes you say that these
relations are globally consistent if
there is a master relation over the
union of the sets of attributes such
that the corresponding projection of the
relation on the set XI gives you the
relation Arab
body it is fairly obvious that if you
have a bunch of relations that are
globally consistent then if you take any
two of them they are pair they are
consistent they are pairwise
consistent the converse is not true
however there are many examples of
relations which are pairwise consistent
but not globally consistent to make it
concrete here is an
example of four relations over uh the
schemas A1 B1 A1 B2 A2 B1 and A2 B2 you
can verify their pa wise consistent and
a little calculation shows that they're
not globally consistent now you may
wonder why I called it hard this Paradox
yes so you sa semantics sa semantics
yeah the b f we'll come we'll come to
this later but this all about set
semantics yes now you may wonder why I
called it hard is paradox this is not
Hardy the number theorist who was
ranjan's advisor this is the physicist
Luan Hardy who in 1993 wrote a very
influential paper that gave another
version of B's theorem and so this
really comes from quantum mechanics
these are the the
the supports of the probability
distributions of some experiments that
you can run in quantum mechanics and
they describe a situation where we have
a bipartite Bel scenario Alice and Bob
they do measurements each has can do two
measurements each measurement has
outcome one A or B one or two outcomes
and this is what comes out this was his
way to give another very compact proof
of bells of bells theorem but I'm not
going to go there I just want to show
you that such situations arise naturally
in different
context so now we come to the crucial
definition which goes back again to
Beal suppose we have a database schema
as a collection of sets of
attributes we say that this has the
local to Global consistency property for
relations if whenever you have a
collection of relations that are
pairwise consistent then they happen to
be globally consistent so this is the
case where we try to overcome the
phenomenon H that we have local
consistency but globally consistency we
want to have a setting in which whenever
you are locally consistent you are also
globally
consistent let's look at some examples
to make sure that such things exist if I
take this schema with sets of attributes
A1 A2 A2 a 3 a 3 A4 it's easy to verify
that this has the local to Global
consistency property for relations this
is the path schema on the other hand
this schema which the cycle of length
four does not have the local Global
consistency property and I showed you an
example hard this hard this Paradox is
an instance that shows that the local to
Global consistency property for
relations fails up to renaming the names
of the attributes Paris is there any
reason why we uh Define local to be
their wise and not like take three you
know and take if they are
consistent so if you have Global
consistency
you
have K kwise consistency for every K
less than M where m is the number of
relations right the the local to Global
was the minimum one and it works for for
this schemas it works for higher
situations as well
okay thank
you so now with this I can State finally
the b in May Yanagi theorem
again we are looking
schemas we want the schemas to have a
local to Global consistency property
meaning there is no difference between
local and Global cons pawise consistency
and Global
consistency
fakis show that if you are given such a
schema the following five statements are
equivalent actually they have like nine
statements I kep just five so that I can
fit them on the slide H is an acyclic
hyper graph what does it mean if I give
you such a schema I can think of it as a
hyper graph whose edges are whose hyper
edges are the sets of attributes and of
course the vertices are the attributes
that I have so there is a notion of an
acyclic hyper graph this equivalent to
hyper graph being conformal and cordal
I'll Define some of these this
equivalent to H have the running
intersection property this equivalent to
H having a joint
three and finally this equivalent to H
having the local to Global consistency
property for
relations now I won't Define c hyper
graph and join three but I do want to
Define conformal and cordal and running
intersection property because these are
H the pieces that we will need to give
the generalization later on for a quick
common question the first for four
properties they are are just properties
of ecity they have nothing to do with
local versus global absolutely thank you
it's coming later you're about five
slides ahead of me H I will praise and
think the appreciation for this theorem
and make exactly the point you are
making that these four properties are
structural the fifth Property is
semantic the four properties have
nothing to do with relations they are
just combinatorial the fifth prop the
fifth Property is semantic and the
beauty of this
is showing that the structural
combinatorial properties are equivalent
to a semantic
property that was exactly
right so what does conformal and cordal
mean if I have a hyper graph we can
associate a graph with this in finite
model Theory we call it the Gan graph
here is called the Primal graph this is
the undirected
graph whose edges are pairs of noes that
appear together H in a at least one
hyper edge of
H and then we say that the hyper graph
is conformal if whenever you have a
click in the Primal graph there is some
hyperedge that contains this click I'll
give you examples in a minute and the
graph and the hyper graph is cordal if
the Primal graph is cordal which means
every cycle of length at least four uh
has a cord has an joining to to
not
yes can you I'm confused so so um
regarding this theorem okay um isn't uh
if you take actually so so there's two
directions to the theorum right two
directions to the theorum right let me
actually take you know just know
property one and property five okay
basically and and and and and prop right
if it's asically it's obviously local
loal property right I think this is
isn't that an obvious statement
I mean depend depends how you define a
city I mean also things that are obvious
to you may not be obvious to me what
want to Define right this is Alpha CC
the definition of a cc is quite
complicated I'm not even going to give
you the definition of joint joint joint
is a
simple take the joint okay yes going
from for five is is is this direction is
easy yes and the other direction if you
have this Hardy example you can always
take this and generates a you know
basically you know approval of this
right you done that it's more
complicated than that believe it's more
complicated than that it actually the
hardest example plays a role not not not
just a hardest example but a collection
of hard type examples it's a minimal
hardest example is a minimal violation
of
cality the hyper graph I mean but there
are others and you need also minimal
counter exams to
conformality to discuss
it so anyway
the the hyper graph is conformal if
every click is contained in some hyper
Edge is cordal if if the Primal graph is
cordal so this hyper graph which is the
which is the path of length three is
both conformal and
cordal uh
there is basically a path H the clicks
are just edges here so there is nothing
more to this this example is conformal
but not cordal because we we have a
cycle of length four but no
cord this example going back to related
to uh what Kristoff said this is the
path the path schema of which which we
have spent the triangle schema which we
have spent a great deal of time talking
about here H this is cordal but not
conformal it is it's cordal because
cycle no no no cycle of Leng for the
Primal graph is a
click but the click is not containing n
your so you have to deal with this case
also it's not just uh the it is not just
Hardis the hyper Gap behind Hardy so the
running intersection property so I
explained what conformal and and and
cordal means the hyper graph has a
running intersection property if there
is an ordering of the hyper
edges such that for every I less than n
there is a j less than I so that x i
intersection with
all the the union of all sets of
attributes of smaller index is contained
in XJ so that's the running intersection
of prop if you have a running
intersection property yes you it's easy
to and they are pairwise consistent it's
easy to build a big relation that
Witnesses the consistency and you you do
a proof of global consistency by
induction this schema we saw before the
path of length three has the running
intersection property the cycle of
length four does not have a running
intersection property you go happily
along up to this point when you throw
this one this one is not contained in
the intersection of one of the previous
there's no previous one such that A4 A1
is contained in the intersection with a
union so cors have the property that you
can always find a ke and if you remove
that it remains cor say that again
please you remove a COR of the
property always find a c yes and remov
of that c it remains REM that c
yes what are the Cs
[Music]
corresponding the Cs are just the edges
here what mean for this one but that
there
is you can't
find it's a
CLE yeah so what I'm not sure understood
your question
Peter you always you think of
thems and they have a click yes find a
click which when
removeal
right we we disc we talk about the
schema being uh conformal or cordal by
reflecting on the Primal graph of
this all right so now uh let me restate
the theorem and make exactly the point
that Dan made that H these four
properties are structural Notions the
three property is a semantic notion
and this theorem tells you that the
semantic properties is equivalent to any
of these four structural properties just
to appreciate the algorithmic
consequence of this
if I gave you this as a definition and
asked you to tell given a hyper graph
does it have a local to Global
consistency property on the face of it
you have to examine all
relations but this
translated says there is a simple
algorithm I mean Computing a joint three
telling if it has joint three and so on
all right now with all this background I
want to go to go to care relations we've
seen a lot of positive semi rings and we
know that positive semi rings are
everywhere so these are some of the
examples we saw this morning so what is
a relation for sorry I don't think we
have we know what the positive sem ring
is Oh I thought so D did not Define this
valid a positive semi ring is a semi
ring that has these two
properties h plus positive means that if
a plus b is zero then a z and b zero and
a * b0 implies that a z or b0 no zero
divisors the way to think about it is
the plus positivity ensures that the sum
of nonzero elements is always non
zero and non zero divid ensures that if
a product is zero at least one of the
factors has to be zero so this is H and
we need both of these properties for the
uh for the results ex a non positive a
ring a ring yeah that's why I stay away
from groups semi ring with to in
determinant yeah it's another example
yeah okay so positive semi rings are
everywhere uh a k relation is simply
what a an ordinary relation where you
have annotations coming from a sing
formally it's a function from a k tles
from n tles to the sem K that has finite
support so it is zero everywhere except
for a finite set relations are B
relations over the Boolean semi ring
bugs or multisets are n relations over
the semi ring of the
integers very important when we
reconcile back with VF theorem
probability distributions of finite
support are R plus relations that's the
semi the non semi ring of the non-
negative numbers with a side condition
that the some of the annotations is
one now I want to define the notion of
consistency for K relations that's where
our work begins we want to generalize
the birin merer yanakakis theorem and
then the Bob theorm so we need the
notion of consistency of relations this
will be done by introducing first an
equivalence relation so we're now having
care relations
overing and we say these two relations
are equivalent
if there are non zero elements so that
when you
multiply the first relation by a and you
multiply the second relation by S you
get B and what do I mean by
multiplication a r is simply the K
relation such that every annotation is
multiplied by
a this is an equivalent relation that's
easy to check let's look what happens
for Boolean relations they're equ valent
if and only if they are equal not true
for bugs okay take a bug
multiply all the multiplicities by the
same number you get an equivalent
relation but they're not equal an
equivalent back but they're not equal on
the other
hand H if I have two probability
distributions of finite support then
they are equivalent in the sense if and
only if they're equal that's a little
exercise using the that the sum of the
probabilities is one moreover if I give
you some relation over the semi ring of
the non- negative reals then there is a
probability distribution of finite
support that's equivalent to it this is
simply normalizing dividing by the sum
of the annotations that you have so
every equivalence class in the seing of
negative reals contains a probability
distribution that's also important for
the connection to bov and now we can
give a definitions as we had
before if we have a bunch of K relations
we say they are globally consistent if
there is a big relation whose
projections now are equivalent to each
of the given relations so we have
replace the quality by equivalence in
the case of buan relations it's old
definition we have the notion of
pairwise consistency in the sense if
they're globally consistent they're
pairwise consistent the coners is true
in general because it's not true even
the Boolean relations so with this now I
can State our main theorem which is what
you the theorem we had before except now
we are talking about an arbitrary
positive semiring and we are talking
about the local to Global consistency
property for K relations which means
that every pairwise consistent
collection of K relations Is globally
consistent so the statement is what we
had before with f Bei
me and yakis except now we are working
with the K relations of an arbitrary
positive seing and here we have the
notion of local to Global consistency 4K
relations the difference one of the
differences as we saw before that Global
consistency means the projections are
not equal they they're equivalent
they're in the same equivalence
class uh the proof has different
architecture than the B F myy
theorem One Direction requires to show I
mean One Direction we saw that if H has
the running intersection property that I
showed you before H
then the H has the local to Global
consistency property for K
relations the second step is that if
it's not conformal or not cordal then it
does not have the local to Global
consistency property for car relations
and of course we are we are appealing to
the four combinatorial characterizations
of of a
cyclicity uh the straightforward
Direction relatively straightforward is
the running intersection property if we
have the running intersection property
we have a local to Global
consistency as you go along though you
need to define the join in the setting
I'm not going to give you a definition
of join I'm I'm going to say it's not
the obvious one if you just multiply the
multiplicity the values doesn't work you
have to do something more sophisticated
I don't have time to get into this the
other direction is perhaps uh more
interesting this is in the spirit of
what kristo commanded if H is not
conformal or H is not cordal then it
contains a simply dued hyper graph which
is
either a minimal violation
of being conformal or a minimal
violation for being cordal one of the
Cycles there is a reduction that says if
you have a local to Global consistency
property for care relations then so do
for some AGS then so do the above simple
induced hyper graphs and now the key
part is that when you look at
this of hyper graphs then this do not
have a local to Global consistency
property Fork relations the proof in
bfmi or or even in bobf doesn't where
you can't use those relations uh we cook
up explicitly construct K relations that
are pairwise consistent not globally
consistent the construction is inspired
uh by proof complexity by titins uh hard
to prove topologies that's all I will
say about this so here is the main
theorem again H is an acyclic hyper
graph if and only if H has the local to
Global consistency property for
relations by specializing to the Boolean
semiring and to the semi ring of the
positive non- negative reals together
with the observation that every
equivalence class there contains a
probability
distribution you have that as a
corollary H is an ayli hyper graph if
only if H has a local to Global
consistency property for relations if
and only if H has a local to Global
consistency property for probability
distributions of finite
support so they are both special case of
this single theorem the equivalence one
and two is the bfm Y what does this have
to do with vf's work I haven't told you
yet was VF theorem in precise terms VF
in 1962 that's 20 plus years before
bfm so that the following are equivalent
for a schema H the hypergraph is
regular and H has the local to Global
consistency property for probability
distributions of finite support what is
regularity I'm not going to define the
notion it's Ain to
Grams H algorithm for eliminating hyper
edges in a hyper graph but in the paper
we give a direct proof that H is regular
if H is a cly so that's these are two
combinatorial Notions so VF theorem and
the bfm theorem are instances of a
single unified result which is what we
wanted to do uh these work appeared in a
volume that just got published in honor
of Samson abramski in outstanding
contributions to
logic and now I want to take a couple of
minutes and finish by describing ongoing
work uh you can step back and see what
did we really use from the positive
semiring well the definition of
projection uses only addition no
multiplication and it's important that
it's positive because otherwise if you
did not have a positive semi ring the
support of a projection would be
different than the support of the
relation you started with things look
really bad where did we use
multiplication obviously we use it in
the def of the equivalence relation
because it said a * Ral B *
s we also use the definition of the join
operation which I didn't show you but
this made us wonder what happens if I
don't have the multiplicative
structure I only have a positive
monoid an operation which is
commutative associative and positive not
no the the sum of two nonzero elements
always on
zero now we can have a stricter notion
of consistency which actually captures
the consistency for bugs two relations
are strictly consistent if there is a k
relation whose projections are the
actual relations not up to equivalence
as we had before this is now perfectly
meaningful for positive
monoids so we can Define analogously the
Notions of strict Global consistency and
strict local to Global consistency for
monoids
so we are almost done writing this new
paper uh we have that if you have the
strict local to Global consistency
property Fork relations for a most
positive mono then it must be a cyclic
so it's a generalization of each side in
construction that I do before but but
there are positive monoids and a cylic
hyper graphs that don't have the local
to Global consistency property for K
relations so the easy
Direction goes bad here the easier
Direction goes bad in fact this happens
even for the path schema there are
positive
monoids for which you don't have you
have three relations in the path schema
they are pairwise consistent they're not
globally consistent in a strict sense we
have succeeded in characterizing the
positive monoids for which every acylic
hyper graph has a strict local to glal
consistency property so we know we have
a combinator characterization of this
the ABS now is that we can forget
semirings and go to positive monoids and
we have a new framework for the study of
local versus global consistency thank
you for your
[Applause]
attention Okay uh so now we go through
the same U the the same thing that we
went before we have half an hour for
extensive discussions oh boy who was
first Eric what puzzles me is that the
structural property does not depend on
the semi ring at all right it just
depends on the
hyper yes so it would mean that if you
have the local to Global consistency for
some hypercraft then you have it for
all nor you want to have it for every
hyper
graph
yes but
uh this
is condition one yes on on the sem
ring doesn't depend on seing no so if
you have this local to Global
consistency for some semi ring then you
have it for that's that's that's that's
that's exactly what it says yes so but
wooded saming is also a samur ring so
yes and that's that's exactly why
degrees that's exactly what
generalizes the there's no difference
between the Boolean and arbitrary
positive sings here as regards the local
to Global consistency Pro
that's okay um not sure um
yes maybe I missed something I'm
wondering if there is some relation
between the notion of kity use in
security and this notion of strict local
and Global
consistency I know the notion of K
anonymity was one of the early attempts
to privacy but it didn't go very well I
mean it went uh yeah I have talked to
bayardo about this a long time ago uh I
don't see it right way but maybe we can
discuss
it so in that uh uh protic version of
the of the problem yeah um so in the
concept contingency tabls you know
people have to this technique called
itative proportion fitting right but
basically so so so you have a number of
tables probabil distributions right you
know marginal from a big thing but
they're noisy so they're in general
inconsistent in it's way they cannot do
the single
probity all the variables right but
usually the assumption is that you got
them by sampling and stuff like that and
and and they're not totally wrong right
and Cas technique fitting for reconstru
the global Universal
relation and there's results about this
that it converges for large class of
things and you get a maxim solution yes
so the question is that I have is there
some version that you know translation
ofing
the I just just a comment at the high
level we want
the local to Global consistent property
to hold for every collection of
relations right this is a different from
the from the decision this is different
from the universal relation problem
where you don't care what the schema is
you say I give you a bunch of relations
they're perir wise consistent are they
globally consistent this static property
this is a static property exactly this
is a static property it is of course it
is interesting only when you have
situations where local consisten does
not imply Global consistency and the
problem is by the old papers
by Johnson yanakakis and Honeyman right
it is it is empty complete to check for
the for the exist of the universal
relation so which of the two problems
you have in mind this question or or the
or the it sounded like you asking about
the the instance version of this right
very that says nothing about the quer
instance right I mean this is a property
this a stat as you said aply it's a
static property of the entire schema my
question have you thought about this
because this is a technique that might
be generalized Beyond distributions
to weights to your but since you
mentioned entropy in the in the paper we
have a section where we try to give some
justification for the choice of the join
because there are many joints you can
select here and we connected it to a
maximum entropy kind of of result and
related this this was related to some
earlier work by Mal in the 80s on
entropy and and the joint but I don't
know if it's related to this I just
going
to just a question to you Kristoff so
when you I don't know the
an but when you compute ipf isn't the
assumption that you start from a set of
consistent marginal distributions well
in the you I have time we do that right
but this thing has develop for the
general scenario where these things are
actually inconsistent but then you get
something inconsistent right they not
like you know you know diagonalized
worst case examples but you're talking
about things where you basically you
know have different ways of basically
you know uh you know creating samples
something like that and basically
reconstructing these different marginal
tables right which you want to be the
global big one I agree it's an it's an
interesting connection inconsistent I
think
yes for the consistency over mono that
you mentioned at begin so is there with
the normal form is it a weaker notion
than noral normal for say Jo dependen or
like and in general is there a concept
foral form
over I don't know how to answer the
question I haven't thought about normal
connection like you have a table that
like on the projection uh uh there is
the stability and on individual
relations they are giving that's that's
the universal relation that that that's
not that is not related to
normal well the universal relation goes
back to to the universal relation model
that Ted Cod F so hardly I mean right
it's the idea that All My Relations are
projections of a master relation Jeff
hulman describes it as the First Data
integration model okay and I think
that's the motivation